by most accounts there is a crisis in
teacher recruitment and retention new
applications were down 29 percent in the
last year and in 2016
nearly 35,000 teachers stopped teaching
for reasons that weren't retirements the
latest government brainwave is to
recruit more is to change the structure
of tests that aspiring teachers need to
pass they'll now be able to reset the
test as many times as they need to but
I'm worried I want the bar for our
teachers to be set high and we must not
lower standards
besides tinkering with tests isn't gonna
solve the crisis in our schools we need
bold radical thinking technical training
more funding incentives to stay in
teaching for the long term we need to
work out exactly what we want our
education system to look like because
what we have now simply isn't working I
[Music]
think there are many reasons why that's
down nearly 30 percent I think some of
it is that and I'd be very frightened if
I was a teacher because all it takes is
one female pupil of 14 to suggest if I
put her hand on my hand on her knee
alright and suddenly my whole career
even though I happened and if a couple
of pupils take against me I am fighting
for my professional why people are I
think some people are concerned I think
some people are concerned now that's why
they might be leaving a genuine thing
that could be a reason but you talk
about more funding I'm always intrigued
by more than it needs more money it
needs more money and I always say if you
gave Ford more money would they make
better cars not necessary just by giving
it more money where does the money go
well you don't spend it on well you know
I'm not somebody who Bank a drum for
more and more money - yeah but the
reason I do in this particular instance
is because I feel embarrassed actually
that we've got schools that are asking
parents to take in stationery and stuff
and essentials that school needs because
they can't that embarrasses me I think
it's absolutely wrong so for me if you
truly cannot afford your own stationery
and stuff like this you've got a problem
going on and we need to look at that and
if we need more funding you've got to
give it but for me there is something
that's broken in our education system I
really feel
and I feel it needs more how does that
manifest itself is that our pupils
aren't doing well is it over you know
why are you saying I don't like the
whole system I don't like the whole
system of one-size-fits-all standardized
testing we measure someone on their can
I think there should be as many tests
Michelle
it's not about as many tests I think for
example I work with a technical college
group and I love what they do they think
very differently they get employers
involved in their curriculum employers
come in and teach these kids go out into
workplaces UTC's they're called they're
absolutely brilliant but they're
different to how schools are set under
standard of modernized schools you don't
think workers oh yeah I think we just
need to think differently and creatively
about how we're educating our kids
because they change the education system
and we've got different sorts of sorts
of schools we've got academies as
opposed to comprehensive in a lot of
places I mean you're arguing about the
tests I think was was pretty irrelevant
if you look over the years if you look
at whether you've talked to a few but if
you look over the years the standards of
people going into teaching has gone up
and up and up I mean well I'm 30 years
ago you didn't have to have a degree
that's gone up now you have to have to
go in to go into teacher training you've
got over to one and you can't just go in
with a 1/3 which it was at one stage but
they've changed this they've changed the
system but I even though I don't get any
just do with why they're leaving I think
they're leaving from for all sorts of it
one of which is esteem is better how can
you say it's better they let me do
something really quickly because Carol I
really want your view but before I do
that you've just said that these
teaching texts are irrelevant
so no
when I saw the pen that's what these
pens yeah because I think we can do it
well I think it's important straight the
kind of questions that we're asking our
teachers to be able to answer in order
to qualify as teachers you're free may
can reset them again and again questions
on these tests and I'm gonna give you an
example are you ready yeah Jimmy your
point is that these are we too easy
Wow we should do a question I'm gonna
give you 15 seconds question number one
during a school trip to Germany every
pupil was allowed to exchange a hundred
pound in two euros the exchange rate was
one point zero six to the pound how many
euros did each pupil receive time
startsnow fifteen seconds to reach 100
pounds in two euros the exchange rate
equals one point zero six to the pound
how many did they get oh yeah you've
only got six okay anything right so I
won't comments the answer is 106 second
question very great day second question
very quickly I'm gonna tell you again
same format question 15 seconds in a in
a group of 110 pupils sixty-six pupils
have school dinners what proportion of
the year group do not have school
dinners and I want your answer in a
decimal 60 seconds so 66 have them what
proportion do not tap them as a decimal
please
ten pupils 6610
right what's your after I'm nothing
right what's your I haven't done it cuz
I die you've got to work out hundred and
times got to become hardened with every
ten three point six the answer is not
point four and my point with that very
simple point what I asked you that first
question your answer was well this is
easy well first of all most so you were
there for expect any teachers that
teaching your kids to be able to answer
such easy question well it depends how
long you get to do the second one I've
proved my point
I think that actually these tests we
shouldn't be lowering the stands if you
can't answer stuff like that first that
first one that you yourself The Times
Higher Education survey last year said
that the university is emitted at
admitting alert of students that are
almost illiterate and it's not
surprising that almost illiterate if led
to who are teaching them can't pass a
literacy or numeracy test this country
languishes a 21 on a world scale for
literacy and 27th to a new recipient
which has to tell you that what's
happening in our schools is not a good
thing and I find it astonishing that the
education minister najib says the most
important thing is not passing tests if
the teachers want to teach and even if
they're not capable of teaching at the
point of entry we should let them in how
many parents are gonna be horrified at
the idea that someone who keeps on
failing tests it's gonna be teaching
their kids the problem we have is lots
of teachers are leaving and not enough
people are entering the profession so
yeah beggars can't be choosey well I
think there's a number of things it's
like what Greg was saying I think money
is a part of it which is why I think we
need to encourage teaching as a second
career there are lots of people who
tried it with the army didn't we need to
figure out a way of doing actually
teaching something actually you could
encourage cuz you older people who teach
first is quite interests you know teach
first basically very black
go straight into teaching now some think
it's a sink or swim yeah you either make
it in social work as well but that's
quite interesting quite a lot of those
kids do actually stay in teaching but
not enough for them because the problem
is those kids then want to go to thought
with less it's well I think it should be
people at the end of their careers who
want to use this as a way that teachers
that actually you can't get people to be
heading for the love of God you can make
people want to take on the
responsibility and have the talent but
you know when a teacher starts off at 22
grand and that's the first way you know
I don't have any truck with them going
on about work workload because they get
14 weeks a holiday yet it no hang on let
me finish you they get 14 weeks are
holiday yet go over the work
however 22 grand is a pitiful salary
when you have the future of our kids
that's my point about why we should
encourage it as a second profession
because you're likely to be able to
afford to be on 22 after 10 years you
only get 34 grand as a salary now some
people on the average wage 20 a graphic
well that's a fortune it's not really
when you have the responsibility of our
kids actually when you in a place in the
big cities where the cost of living so
much